anthony et thibaut près par une voiture
les autres équipements sont déjà
arrivées atrium dans le sud est des
états unis pour le mondial des jeux
équestres
cet après midi il s'entraînait l'une de
leurs épreuves celle du marathon
l'équipe qui part avec moi c'est
vraiment trois amis et trois copains
sportifs avec qui on échange beaucoup on
va je vais profiter de leur expérience
et donc je suis assez j'allais dire pas
serein mais si on peut dire serein pour
partir avec ces mecs là avec cette
équipe là et avec des chevaux qui vont
deux jours d'entraînement intensif
attentes ses deux meneurs éviter les
obstacles fait d'une série de couloir et
le plus vite possible
c'est le but de cette épreuve de
marathon agilité puissance et rigueur
sont de mise c'est justement ce qui
créative moi j'ai commencé à mon avis
comme tous les jeunes sur des poneys
mais il ya un moment donné le physique
m'a rattrapé et donc quand on fait un
métier de 25 des 110 kg c'est plus
facile d'être sur une voiture que sur le
dos d'un cheval ou alors après c'est
plus un choix mais ça ma mousse et du
coup ça a commencé comme ça avec le papa
et puis petit à petit j'ai commencé à 2
puis ba2 et le premier de l'attelage à
quatre c'est qu'une fois qu'on a goûté
aux quatre c'est la complexité qui rend
la chose passionnante
du côté de l'entraîneur l'optimisme
règne dans ce qui est prévu le tout de
manière ici c'est de se battre et de se
battre pour essayer de faire un podium
c est réellement difficile on sait que
les hollandais normalement seront devant
et puis à la belgique l'allemagne et la
france pour se battre pour les deux
autres places pour habituer les coureurs
l'état du gué les chevaux traverse un
obstacle d'eau rendez vous le 11
septembre date du début des jeux
équestres mondiaux